inside our head we are always alone even
when we are with others physically we
still remain alone in ourselves
throughout life we often seek things
like drugs to help us numb this feeling
of isolation drugs make it fun to be
alone they D familiarize us from our
self and for a little while we feel what
it means to exist separate from our
usual brain patterns we become okay with
being alone because for a brief and
fleeting moment it feels like we are not
but we soon sober up and find ourselves
deeper and more attached to loneliness
than ever before so how can we eliminate
our feeling of loneliness and instead
produce and sustain a feeling of
connection and disembodiment without
depending on intoxicating substances to
induce it instead of trying to numb our
sense of loneliness we must accept and
embrace it we cannot tap into any sense
of collectivity until we have first
embraced what it takes to exist as an
individual we must sit with and learn
from our loneliness we must experience
its confusion sadness and pain through
this we can then begin to explore
corners of ourself that we otherwise
would never visit we can learn from the
depth of our lonesomeness and form it
into a unique and valuable self we can
then use our newfound self to develop
strong and genuine social connections
because we will have developed depth and
sincerity in our character
we will be able to plug our loneliness
into the collective exchange of life and
personality and we will soon begin to
feel less and less alone
[Music]